en este vídeo hablaremos un poco sobre
soldadura
este es un cautín para soldar la punta
del cautín puede ponerse muy caliente
puede llegar hasta 350 a 450 grados
celsius dependiendo del cautín así que
es muy importante que jamás jamás toques
nada del metal siempre sostiene el
cautín como sostienes por ejemplo un
lápiz o un bolígrafo pues eso te da un
buen control sobre el cautín y cuando no
lo estés utilizando siempre debe estar
en su soporte así que jamás jamás lo
sostengas mientras esperas algo o haces
otra cosa siempre déjalo en su soporte y
así también no tocar algo que no quieres
quemar también tiene en mente que el
cable del cautín puede llegar a jalarse
así que asegúrate de que el cable no
caiga por donde están tus piernas y
tampoco esté a la orilla de la mesa para
que de esta manera no se enrede por
equivocación y se jale
también cuida de nunca dejar el cable
así que esté tocando el cautín porque
entonces bueno se va a derretir y eso
puede ocasionarte problemas puede
ocasionar un corto por ejemplo ya verás
que soldar es divertido pero no queremos
accidentes entonces lo primero debes
usar lentes de seguridad ponte los no
olvides los lentes de seguridad y
también asegúrate de tener el soporte
para tu cautín porque esto va a mantener
a tu cautín estable y otra cosa es bueno
también tener un ventilador encendido
porque el ventilador te va a ayudar a
alejar el humo que se produce al estar
soldando y ahora esto que tenemos aquí
se llama tercer brazo tiene dos pinzas
de caimán las cuales te ayudan a colocar
lo que tú quieres soldar en una posición
estable asegúrate que la parte a soldar
esté sujeta siempre en posición estable
entonces bueno vamos a usar vamos a usar
este alambre y uniremos esta esta parte
simplemente trenzando los extremos y
claro la soldadura sostendrá la parte
también es bueno tener un buen ajuste
mecánico muy bien entonces ya vamos a
soldar un poco la parte que entrelazamos
ahora recuerda también hay que limpiar
primero la punta del cautín entonces
bueno como hacemos esto tomamos la
soldadura y ponemos un poco de soldadura
en la punta del cautín y bueno ya que
está eso se lo quitamos si se cae
inmediatamente
después vamos a tomar el cautín y lo
vamos a sostener contra el metal el
metal se calienta rápidamente y tú
puedes ver que como el metal está
caliente la soldadura está fluyendo o
cayendo encima del metal con mucha
facilidad
de hecho date cuenta que no fue
necesario que la punta del cautín y la
soldadura se tocaran la soldadura tocó
solamente al metal que entrelazamos baja
solamente tocaba el alambre entonces
bueno es importante siempre tocar con la
soldadura la parte que tú quieres
conectar tocar con la soldadura y no con
el cautín porque la soldadura se une
cuando el metal está caliente y también
puedes ver qué
sale un poco de humo ese humo es de la
soldadura tú no quieres respirar eso por
eso es bueno tener un ventilador o una
ventana abierta pero en fin ahí ya
tienes la parte conectada ahí está
siempre asegúrate de que la parte esté
bien asegurada y bueno aquí ya está la
pieza que soldamos entonces estás
preparado para soldar así que manos a la
obra